aquí tengo dos distintas definiciones
para la función de dt
y por ejemplo en el primer caso tenemos
que de dt es igual a 3 t más 1 y quizás
podemos imaginar que de representar una
distancia como función del tiempo ok
entonces la distancia por supuesto
estará medida en metros y el tiempo
estará medido en segundos así que por
aquí en la primera cuando te es igual a
cero es decir cuando cuando empezamos a
contar el tiempo la distancia es un
centímetro un metro perdón un metro y
después de un centro de un segundo
perdón la distancia será cuatro verdad
porque tres por uno es tres más uno es
cuatro entonces más o menos corresponde
a este punto muy bien cuando tenemos dos
segundos pues tendremos tres por dos son
seis más uno
7 que más o menos corresponde a este
punto de aquí y así podríamos marcar los
puntos que corresponden a la gráfica de
esta función así que dada esta
definición de ddt cuál es la tasa de
cambio de la distancia respecto del
tiempo y de hecho esto que estoy
diciendo la tasa de cambio lo vamos a
denotar de la siguiente forma es la tasa
de cambio de la distancia con respecto
al tiempo en realidad algunas personas
por ejemplo a esto es a lo que le
conocen como la velocidad verdad y este
triángulo no es en realidad un triángulo
es simple es una letra griega es la
letra griega delta delta mayúscula y
esencialmente se traduce digamos como
cambio verdad es el cambio en la
distancia dividido entre el cambio del
tiempo y eso es justamente la tasa de
cambio de la distancia respecto del
tiempo muy bien entonces vamos a ver
cómo cómo sería esto
por ejemplo si nosotros partimos de este
punto cuando usted es igual a 0 y nos
movemos a cuando te vale 1 aquí tenemos
un cambio en el tiempo igual a 1 verdad
cuál sería el cambio en la distancia con
este con este cambio en el tiempo
bueno pues esencialmente tendremos que
movernos desde 1 hasta 4 verdad entonces
nuestro cambio en la distancia es 3
vamos de 1 a 4
eso es 3 y entonces nuestra tasa de
cambio de la distancia respecto de la
velocidad perdón el respecto del tiempo
es justamente es la velocidad y eso es
el cambio en la distancia son 3 metros
dividido entre el cambio en el tiempo
que es un segundo verdad y esto lo
podríamos simple bueno vamos a dejarlo
así muy bien entonces ustedes podrán
pensar bueno y por qué tomarlo con estos
dos puntos qué pasa si partimos ente
igual a 1 y nos movemos
igual a 2 verdad qué pasaría si ahora
tomamos este cambio en el tiempo cuál
sería el cambio en la distancia bueno
ahora vamos de 4 a 7 que esencialmente
son 3 metros de diferencia de verdad y
aumentamos un segundo entonces
nuevamente tenemos la misma la misma
tasa de cambio verdad y en realidad no
importa dónde o qué par de puntos
tomemos verdad esto es esencialmente un
repaso si tomamos dos puntos sobre esta
sobre esta línea sobre esta gráfica de
hecho es justamente la misma tasa de
cambio ese es una de las cosas que
define a una línea verdad que va a tener
la misma tasa de cambio porque será lo
que defina una línea bueno esencialmente
porque estamos midiendo el cambio en la
posición vertical dividido entre el
cambio en la posición horizontal y eso
tiene un nombre y es justamente la
pendiente verdad esto es justamente la
pendiente
esta línea por ejemplo para esta línea
en particular la pendiente es 3 la
pendiente es igual a 3 y eso lo podremos
todavía confirmar más en la definición
de la función desde de verdad este es
una función lineal que está escrita en
forma pendiente ordenada al origen así
que aquí está la pendiente verdad aquí
está la pendiente y esta es la ordenada
al origen esencialmente es donde
intersecta al eje vertical verdad por
ejemplo y eso se ve cuando usted es
igual a cero y esto es uno que es justo
lo que vemos aquí pero bueno todo eso es
pendiente si esto te parece muy extraño
o quizás muy ajeno a lo que tú conoces
te recomiendo que vean los vídeos de
khan academy sobre rectas y formas punto
pendiente y todos esos temas pero bueno
vamos a seguir adelante qué pasaría por
ejemplo en el caso de la derecha ahora
no tenemos una línea sino que tenemos
una curva que es una parábola verdad es
una función cuadrática así que esto se
vuelve muy interesante vamos a ver por
qué
si digamos esta gráfica está definida
por la función de cuadrada más 1 ahora
esa va a ser nuestra definición de ddt
esto es muy interesante porque ahora la
tasa de cambio está cambiando también
está cambiando a verdad por ejemplo si
nosotros tomamos un punto aquí si
nosotros tomamos un punto aquí y vemos
cómo es la pendiente de una recta
tangente quizás debería no hacerlo tan
grueso si vemos la pendiente
recta tangente verdad parece ser muy
pronunciada a diferencia de por ejemplo
si tomamos la recta tangente que pasa
por este punto o quizás por este punto
entonces vemos que la pendiente de estas
rectas tangentes cada vez se va
volviendo más y más pronunciado verdad a
medida que el tiempo avanza así que esto
nos da una buena noción de que la tasa
de cambio de la distancia con respecto
al tiempo también crece de verdad así
que por esto nos preguntamos bueno cómo
pensamos en la tasa de cambio de una
variable respecto de otra si además de
todo están cambiando verdad suena
trabalenguas pero así es y más adelante
verás que esencialmente de esta pregunta
se trata todo el cálculo diferencial
pero por ahora contamos con otra
herramienta más adecuada más adecuada a
lo que conocemos hasta ahora y eso es la
tasa de cambio promedio la tasa de
cambio
lo escribí mal la tasa de cambio
promedio muy bien por supuesto que la
tasa de cambio promedio no nos va a
hablar de las de las tasas de cambio
instantáneas como por ejemplo lo
habíamos visto en estas tres líneas que
había dibujado verdad pues es mucho más
sencillo pensar en la tasa de cambio
promedio y es también muy parecido al
caso anterior por ejemplo para hacer
esto vamos a tomarnos dos puntos sobre
esta sobre esta gráfica por ejemplo
podemos tomarnos cuando usted es igual a
cero y cuando usted es igual a tres muy
bien y ahora vamos a trazar la recta
secante que conecta a estos dos puntos
también tenemos ahí dicha recta secante
y esto digamos la la pendiente de esta
recta secante es exactamente la tasa de
cambio promedio desde t igual a 0 hasta
t igual a 3 verdad y de hecho no así no
es instantánea porque la tasa de cambio
instantánea va cambiando se va volviendo
cada
es más y más pronunciada en este caso
por ejemplo crecería la tasa de cambio
instantánea pero con esta definición de
la tasa de cambio promedio podemos tener
una muy buena nación de qué es lo que
está pasando en un intervalo de tiempo
entonces como calculamos esto pues
esencialmente lo hacemos muy similar al
caso anterior calculamos calculamos el
aumento en el tiempo en la distancia
perdón dividido en el cambio en el
tiempo verdad los incrementos son los
cambios como calculamos ahora el
incremento en la distancia
bueno pues partimos de o más bien
concluimos en d evaluado en tres verdad
sería como nuestro punto final que eso
es muy fácil de calcular verdad ahorita
vemos cuánto es estrés al cuadrado 9 más
1 son 10 más o menos aquí está el 10
aunque y aquí estaría el 10 y le
restamos de donde partimos que era de
evaluado en cero que es uno verdad aquí
está el 1 dividido entre el cambio en el
tiempo en nuestro tiempo final fue 3 y
le restamos el tiempo inicial que era 0
muy bien entonces esto es muy fácil de
calcular de hecho aquí mismo aquí mismo
podemos ver cuál es el cambio
la distancia y esencialmente tenemos que
ir de 1 a 10 verdad entonces la
distancia en el tiempo igual a 3 es
igual a 3 al cuadrado 9 más 110 ya lo
habíamos visto y la distancia en el
tiempo pero es uno verdad entonces 10
menos 1 nos da 9 dividido entre 3 -0 que
es que es 3 y 9 entre 3 son 3 verdad y
por supuesto si tenemos cuidado con las
unidades serían metros sobre segundo
verdad porque arriba tenemos una
distancia y abajo teníamos un tiempo
medido en segundos muy bien pero no
necesariamente tendríamos que haberlo
hecho en estos dos puntos verdad qué
pasaría si hubiéramos tomado no sea lo
mejor para t igualados de igualados y t
igual a igual a 3 también por ejemplo
así que si tomamos esos dos puntos ahora
el t igualados y t igual a 3 tenemos
esta nueva recta secante
que primero podemos ver que es mucho más
pronunciada que la que teníamos
anteriormente vamos a ver que esto es
cierto como es la tasa de cambio de la
distancia respecto al tiempo es decir la
tasa de cambio promedio en este digamos
respecto a estos 22 tiempos ok vamos a
ver cómo cambia la distancia con
respecto al tiempo y esto esencialmente
es nuestra nuestra distancia final que
es la distancia al tiempo t igual a 3 y
le restamos la distancia al tiempo t
igualados verdad estamos calculando
esencialmente este aumento desde este
punto hasta este otro punto muy bien
ahora sería este nuestro nuestro cambio
en la distancia dividido entre la el
cambio en el tiempo verdad que en este
caso es nuestro tiempo final es 3 menos
el tiempo inicial que es 2 ahora bien
esto ya lo habíamos calculado la
distancia entre igual a 13 10
- la distancia entre igualados sería 2
al cuadrado 41 son 5 si son
muy bien y ahora dividimos entre 3 menos
2 que es 1 y esto nos da 10 menos 5 son
5 dividido entre 1 son 5 y otra vez las
unidades son metros sobre segundo muy
bien esto es bastante interesante porque
resulta hacer que la tasa de cambio
promedio también cambia dependiendo de
qué puntos nos tomemos sobre esta
gráfica así por ejemplo para esta esta
recta secante tenemos una tasa de cambio
de 5 metros sobre segundo mientras que
para esta esta otra recta secante
tenemos una tasa de cambio promedio de 3
metros sobre el segundo así que esto te
debe dar una muy buena idea de cómo
cambia la tasa de cambio promedio y
digamos cómo cambia a medida que t
el tiempo es muy pequeño o quizás cuando
te crece mucho verdad y esto creo que es
una muy buena probadita de lo que es el
cálculo diferencial